hi my name is Kyle Valle here with big
squid productions and today I wanted to
talk to you a little bit about camera
toys and how it can help you to achieve
the look and feel that you're trying to
get out of your video content currently
we're working on a project entitled
zombie con okay this is a cosplay action
horror thriller following a group of
cosplayers as they take the streets of
Los Angeles by storm braving a zombie
apocalypse in order to save who else but
mom so in regards to researching the
look right you have to spend a lot of
time checking out your source material
it's something here time and time again
but really you cannot spend enough time
in pre-production now don't handicap
yourself by just using it as an excuse
not to get started set a firm date
that's going to be reasonable and that's
something that you can actually fulfill
and stick to that okay because it's
important that you keep moving at a
steady pace you don't want to sit in
pre-production for 30 years it's not
gonna help anyone in regards to finding
the look for zombie come we've shot a
great teaser that's using a lot of
standardized filmmaking techniques we
shot at 4k put a lot of work put a day's
worth of work into it with two people
crew as usual but for us you know we put
our time and made it look nice now for
zombie con itself we're gonna be doing
something a little bit different we're
gonna be trying to really bring out the
anime visual element and those and I
can't stress you enough the heavy
contrast that's that's forcing the
bodies to pop off the page camera that
will be using chiefly for zombie con is
this right here the Blackmagic Cinema
Camera I'm really happy with this choice
and the reason that we chose it in order
to give it the desired effect was the
fact that it shot in 4k it came with the
DaVinci Resolve package this allows you
to really have a great deal of
flexibility and post and really lets you
lock down exactly the color temperature
the saturation of the contrast that you
really want
so getting the feel the look the taste
whatever of your film you should
certainly look into you know 4k cameras
cameras with a lot of they're gonna give
you a lot of digital information so that
you can really play with and Bend those
colors and post and get exactly what you
want out of it that being said this is
an expensive option a lot of add-ons and
a lot of things that you need to kind of
put around this thing in order to get to
work the way you want it also has to be
balanced with your budget everything in
your production needs to be balanced
it's not just a camera it's the lighting
it's how you
the camera it's what you know what your
actors are doing obviously all that
stuff but cinematography wise lenses
lighting camera all important all need
to work for your budget
and you can't sacrifice one in order to
go for the other okay you got to try to
find a way to balance all those things
together and that's another really
important part of your pre-production
top three choices in camera would have
to be you know the big boy toys the re
Alexa the red epic dragon you know stuff
that really has that kind of industry
standard stamped on it already but you
know that's not in everyone's wheelhouse
it certainly wasn't in our wheelhouse so
we had to find a creative solution
within our budget in order to solve that
problem it all comes down to this
situation what are you using the camera
for what is your budget and what is the
look that you're trying to achieve to
research the cameras I did what I'm sure
all of you do whenever it is that you
have any question right I got online I
looked up every single tutorial every
single you know vlog about these things
trying to understand it from every
single side it wasn't just about the
pros or the cons it was trying to find
the people who were skewed to both end
and the people in the middle from there
I gathered all that information and I
made a determination based upon my needs
and based upon my budget and ultimately
that's what it always comes back to
balance yourself balance your production
balance your budget
whenever you're researching a camera
there's not really a given amount of
time that I can arbitrarily say is the
right amount of time for you okay it's
all depending on what type of materials
or sources that you find and how
reliable you think those sources or
materials are now with both of these
cameras I found a great deal of helpful
and not so helpful things online just
you know as you always will but I wanted
to properly vet them we're making big
financial decisions and especially in
the case of the Blackmagic you're not
just talking about you know a couple
thousand dollars you're talking about
ten thousand dollars plus with all the
cool toys that you need to actually get
it working in the way in which it is
intended to work so it's a big
investment and you don't want to make
the wrong decision so take as much time
as you need to feel comfortable with it
when you can go to that buy button and
feel utterly comfortable with that
decision apart from you know feeling a
little bit squeaky about actually
sending the money but you know it's the
right thing to do and you in your heart
in your mind and your body are like yes
and now you're just turned to excitement
mode then do it but be honest with
yourself and people always get that
wrong right they feel yes but they
haven't been honest to themselves they
haven't actually looked at what the
counter points are they watch all the
positive reviews they don't watch the
negative reviews because they're
mentally skewed to one in their favor so
just take your time do a proper amount
of research look up both sides and when
you feel comfortable pull the trigger
the most important factors in my final
decision were budget quality usability
and most importantly for me how much
could I trust the company that's selling
me the product now I have to say that
both of these companies after working
with them do a wonderful job in customer
support and that fact cannot be
overlooked a lot of people will shave
off a few dollars and then end up with
the product that doesn't work and that
they can't find any help with so make
sure you trust the company make sure you
trust the product make sure it works for
your budget and then you're good while
researching these cameras I didn't
really reach out to my filmmaker friends
to ask what they were using most of them
use things like an Ari Alexa or red epic
dragon some you know the big boy toys
and I didn't feel as if they had had as
much actual usability with these cameras
now obviously they've used them before
they're used to working with these
extremely expensive rigs and I just
thought we were and we were talking at
different points it might be talking
past each other a little bit so I really
trusted the internet I trusted the
people that I was watching I trusted the
tutorials that I was watching I trusted
all there were user reviews that I was
watching now not just arbitrarily mind
you as I discussed before it's all about
trying to watch both ends of the
spectrum trying to find the guy in the
middle then trying to balance all of
those things together and you also have
to look at something like
trustworthiness how much do you trust a
person giving you the information so
just things to take into account so I
guess yes and no did I ask filmmakers
for advice no I did not did I get a
whole bunch of advice from filmmakers
absolutely strengths and weaknesses 4k
raw that's your strengths weakness this
thing needs like three cases worth a
gear in order to get it set up and
like make it happen the black magic
fails pretty miserably in terms of
shooting on the fly now we've taken it
right off stakes we've taken it with
just the lens running on there and we've
gotten some pretty amazing stuff but
it's an awkward shape it's hard to hold
and you're finding those shots to be a
little bit shaky you want to get an
Adobe after-effects and throw in a warp
stabilizer that's gonna fix a lot of
your problems as long as you got steady
hands but at the same time I always feel
uncomfortable holding this thing even
with the cage kind of aloft without any
type of rigging below it you know you
drop it boom that's the end of that this
the Canon c100 which is our most recent
camera that we've purchased is great now
we're using this for zombie con as well
we're using this for more of the you
know info tutorials the video blogs and
vlogs and other things that were
uploading onto the site as well as a way
for our characters to interact with the
audience in a more virtually interactive
way a production company perch's these
cameras because they're things that we
use almost every day we're working you
know seven days a week nearly twelve
hours a day we never really get out of
the studio and we're just really filming
filming filming filming filming filming
filming filming filming filming and
guess what we're filming so renting them
was not going to be a feasible option
for us nor was it going to be a
financially you know incentivized one
we're gonna be losing money hand over
fist paying other people in order to
rent these cameras and ultimately not
getting any type of long-term benefit
also it becomes a little bit tough if
you're in a pinch and all of a sudden
you need a camera can't get one can't
find one can't rent one you know you
could there could be some problems there
so in order to be professional in order
to be ready around the clock whenever we
needed to buy them and that's what we
did
lenses and with every as with every
purchase lenses included you have to
take a substantial amount of time and as
I described with the camera there's no
set amount of time to do that you know
we've got to set up think about seven or
eight lenses and I spent a very amount
of time on each one of those lenses to
decide whether or not it was the right
lens for us but that being said you need
to do your work you need to get out
there you need to watch a ton of videos
and you need to wait until you feel
comfortable making that purchase only
you are going to be able to be the one
who decides ultimately when it is that
you know enough okay my timeline or
anyone else isn't going to help you with
that for the Blackmagic we've got a set
of
or prime lenses in regards to that I
mean it totally matters a little shy I
love the bokeh the 50 gives you but the
85 is super sharp right we go down to 24
or 35 or 16 even a 14 all different I'll
give you differing effects and each one
fits a different place so just like
everything else there isn't a favorite
there isn't one thing that Trump's all
it's all about balance and it's all
about balancing what you need with what
you have with what you can get for what
your final result needs to be is at the
end of the day there's good things and
bad things not really in the middle so
make sure you do what you need to do to
balance everything you need to to get to
the good end like with the cameras we
bought all of our lenses just because we
use them so readily it wouldn't be
fiscally irresponsible for us to rent
those lenses because we would end up
spending and incurring more costs and
rental fees than we would have if we
actually just bought the lenses to start
with that being said we're about to get
into our feature film production of
zombie con you can check that on
IndieGoGo but we will be renting the
lenses for that and that's because we
want to step our lens game up we want to
get into using some serious prime lenses
and we're talking about a twenty
thousand dollar kit in order to buy
those and we're just not in a financial
position to buy those it all comes down
to what type of lens you're trying to
use how expensive is that lens and how
often do you plan on using that lens now
if I was using a $20,000 lens kit on a
daily basis and I was making money off
of that well then the only responsible
thing to do would be to buy those lenses
did we get the look we wanted with these
cameras in journeymen yes I got exactly
what I wanted I knew we were shooting at
422 HQ I knew that we weren't shooting
in 4k Ron I knew that we had a couple of
limitations with that we were also
shooting so that was very visually
appealing for something like on an
iPhone or a tablet it wasn't just for
the big screen while also still making
it very watchable on the big screen that
being said we learned a lot from those
experiences and with this upcoming
zombie con project we're gonna be
shooting the entire thing in 4k I want
complete maneuverability flexibility and
control over the color space over the
saturation and over everything else that
I need to work on in the back end so we
can give you guys the best coolest
looking product thanks again guys my
name is Kyle Valle and for me and all
the squids here big squid productions we
loved hanging out with you guys
say and hope this was helpful and that
helped you with your next project look
forward to seeing you on the IndieGoGo
page for zombie con